[Música]
estoy conectada sí bueno muy buenos días
a todos ya todas estoy realmente muy
feliz de estar en teresa pote mi nombre
es milena y me parece que este es un
momento extraordinario para compartirles
cuál es cuál es y ha sido mi pasión de
vida que ha sido la defensa de los
derechos de la niñez es las
adolescencias y las juventudes en costa
rica y donde sea que que mi destino me
lleve
yo
desde desde
desde muy desde muy el recorrido de este
camino por muchas más décadas de las que
me quiero recordar y una de las cosas
que ha aprendido y por eso quise titular
mi charla todo cambia es que en la vida
todo cambia y que realmente uno tiene
que estar listo como los decían las
personas que estaban acá antes uno tiene
que estar listo para aprovechar ese
cambio no tenerle miedo y hacer de y
hacerle frente y para para estar listo
para no tenerle miedo a ese cambio para
hacerle frente es precisamente para lo
que sirve el aprendizaje penal el
aprendizaje permanente es quiero hablar
de eso hoy quiero hablar poco y decirles
mucho ahora porque hay mucho que decir
sobre el aprendizaje permanente el
aprendizaje permanente no lo quiero
hablar desde la teoría sino quiero
hablarlo desde un modelo mental me da
una forma de vivir la vida que ha
marcado la mía entonces decirles en ese
sentido que el aprendizaje permanente
parte de proponer
este modelo que llevo a mi generación
sin mayor sobresalto de la familia a la
escuela de la escuela alcohol el
instituto a la universidad de allí al
trabajo del trabajo a la pareja verdad
de la pareja a la pensión y de la
pensión a la tumba eso se acabó ahora ya
no hay una línea tan tan clara tan
sostenida ustedes desde muy jóvenes les
ha tocado vivir un mundo que es complejo
e incierto verdad y eso está ahí los
cambios han llegado y van a seguir
llegando y realmente lo que uno tiene
que hacer es ver de qué manera se asumen
esos cambios como trampolín para llegar
a lo mejor a donde uno ni siquiera nunca
lo había pensado
y para eso precisamente sirve el el
aprendizaje permanente para que uno esté
en todas cómodas y pueda uno identificar
ya solo son los riesgos las las
complejidades que van llegando a
nuestras vidas
los lados y que podamos más bien usarlos
verdad cómo convertirlos apropiar esos
riesgos y convertirlos en oportunidades
el aprendizaje permanente establece
[Música]
y digamos un punto de partida que es
importante y el punto de partida es qué
es ese pensamiento esa visión de la
familia para estar y del cole para
aprender hay que hay que dejarla atrás
que el aprendizaje permanente es algo
que ocurre en muchísimos espacios en
muchísimos momentos y que si bien están
las instituciones que están la escuela
el instituto de la universidad que están
hechas para enseñarnos la realidad es
que nosotros aprendemos podemos aprender
todo el tiempo en todo lado mi vida como
la de ustedes ha sido hecha de momentos
verdad de aprendizajes
en los más diversos en mi familia de
origen en la familia con la que me tocó
nacer en la familia que hice más
adelante con tres hijos una hija y un
nieto que se llama antonio quedamos por
toda la vida en las amistades y no
amistades que me busquen a lo largo del
tiempo y en las relaciones de trabajo
que he podido desarrollar a lo largo de
eso y sobre todo en el uso que le he
dado a mi tiempo el tiempo libre y el
tiempo ocupa de el uso que le he dado
ayer que le estoy dando hoy con ustedes
celebrando esta esta reunión y en el que
le quiero dar mañana
la otra cosa que propone el aprendizaje
permanente es que
aprender y enseñar son dos caras de una
misma moneda
y que todos y todas de alguna manera
somos aprendices
y maestros en la vida y que hay cosas
que
digamos que uno puede descubrir en las
relaciones más impensadas
pero quiero compartirles dos
aprendizajes que han de algún
aprendizaje que tuve muy temprano en la
vida mía que marcó realmente mi vida un
aprendizaje que yo creo que está en la
raíz de cualquier cosa buena que yo
puedo haber hecho en este tiempo y
después quiero compartir lo que sucedió
en mi familia de origen y después quiero
compartirles algo mucho más reciente más
fresco que había tocado vivir ya más
crecidita y es mi participación en un
proyecto maravilloso el limón que se
llama trayectorias juveniles y aquí
están los chicos y las chicas a quienes
saludó la con gran entusiasmo
que todos los días me hace levantarme
con entusiasmo y con ganas de vivir la
vida bueno vamos con mi familia
[Música]
ahí debería estar la foto una foto de mi
mamá con amigos chiquititos bueno
déjenme decirles que mi papá y mis dos
hermanas mayores murieron en un
accidente aéreo cuando yo tenía nueve
meses mi mamá la quedó viuda desolada
con ese dolor inmenso y con la
responsabilidad de la familia que les
quedábamos un hermano de 16 años dos
hermanas mías de 12 de 11 y 12 años y yo
como bebé tenía el derecho de haberse
encerrado en su dolor de haber sido
olvidado del mundo de haberse olvidado
de nosotros a ver quién se hacía cargo
pero no lo hizo no lo hizo
se plantó firme en su nueva realidad se
hizo cargo de ganarnos la casa de luz y
de alegría y se hizo hizo su razón de
vida acompañarnos y enseñarnos a crecer
ya tratar de ser en cada momento la
mejor versión de nosotros mismos esa es
mi mamá y está en la foto y esta soy yo
de aguas rayas verdad conforme fuimos
avanzando como forma yo fui creciendo y
procesando que era aquello que había
pasado
y cuando ya era una bebé me di cuenta de
las enseñanzas aprendizajes que mamá me
había transmitido en ese momento pero la
primera era que en la vida todo es
actitud yo no puede hacerle frente a las
cosas más duras y más severas verdad si
uno se planta fuerte y sobre todo si uno
piensa en sí mismo y si piensa en otros
otra cosa que me enseñó mamá
era que el miedo no era el era el peor
enemigo que nosotros podemos tener y que
hay que reconocerlo y echarlo a un lado
para hacer y la tercera cosa que aprendí
yo de mamá y es que estas cosas que yo
aprendí de mamá en mi casa que son parte
del aprendizaje permanente que ha
marcado mi vida son las cosas que yo
siempre quiero compartir con las
personas jóvenes niños niñas y con
colegas con los que trabajo todo el día
la tercera cosa que me hace que saque de
esa experiencia era que el aprendizaje
permanente no siempre es fácil ni
divertido ni alegre que a veces es muy
muy doloroso pero que siempre forja
carácter por eso la heroína que tenemos
ahí siempre forja carácter
ahora vamos a pasar a trabajo ok que es
el otro espacio que quería compartirles
esto viene de una experiencia como les
decía que se llama a trayectorias
juveniles y tienen que ver un poco con
reflexiones que se han hecho antes en
este espacio
pensar que en este mundo que el futuro
no es el futuro sobre todo y ustedes que
son jóvenes va a ser una repetición de
lo que está pasando ahora verdad es
absolutamente no es ni inteligente ni
útil pensar que con una nadita de perro
en el cole en el instituto o en el
trabajo uno a salir adelante es algo que
hay que desechar es un mundo competitivo
y nosotros tenemos que estar siempre
aprovechando los espacios y los momentos
para aprender en ese marco el limón hay
un proyecto que se llama tallas
historias juveniles cuya propuesta es
invitar jóvenes que quieren salir
adelante de limón que en este momento no
estaban estudiando ni trabajando para
que sean parte de un proceso y entre
todos construyamos aprendizajes y
construyamos aprendizajes de cómo sería
estar en el mundo del trabajo para
buscar nuevas alternativas de vida esa
es una parte pero el proyecto tiene una
la formación basada en el puesto de
trabajo como una de las de los
componentes
al
eso quiere decir que a la parte de los
jóvenes de las juventudes que están
desarrollando hay un grupo de empresas
más de 30 de limón que están abriendo
sus puertas para que los chicos y las
chicas del proyecto vayan al mundo del
trabajo prueben ahí se pongan a prueba y
lo que han aprendido con el proyecto
pero además las empresas también quieren
este enseñarles cosas adicionales cosas
que no se aprenden en ningún aula pero
que se aprenden en el mundo laboral
verdad como como cómo es cómo se
comporta uno en el mundo laboral cómo se
relaciona con los compañeros de trabajo
cómo conversa con el jefe como cómo uno
contribuye éxito del negocio como uno se
vuelve una persona necesaria una persona
capaz de aportar a que todas las cosas
fluyan de mejor manera la cómo se pone
una chaqueta de un trabajo
y cómo y cómo está ahí esas cosas
maravillosas que nosotros no se las
podemos enseñar en el proyecto se las
enseñan los empresarios y las
empresarias en sus
sus vidas pero como el aprendizaje
permanente dijimos que todos somos todos
enseñamos y todos aprendemos resulta que
los chicos y las chicas también las
sencillas han enseñado a los empresarios
cosas las les han enseñado que las
juventudes están ahí que quieren ser
parte del cambio que son necesarios para
el cambio que son confiables que saben
rendir que saben aportar al crecimiento
de la empresa pero ahí entonces es han
aprendido de eso pero los dos grupos han
aprendido otra cosa que es para nosotros
lo más maravillosa que han aprendido han
aprendido que pueden mirarse a los ojos
verdad confiar
uno en otro y trabajar juntos porque esa
no era la visión antes de que la
formación basada en el puesto de trabajo
entrara como un componente de nuestro
proyecto
durantes había desconfianza y reticencia
de un lado para otro y ahora estamos ahí
eso es lo que sea porque es lo que ha
aprendido yo milena
esta experiencia con las empresas con
los chicos y con las chicas de esta
experiencia de aprendizaje para mí en el
mundo del trabajo bueno he aprendido he
confirmado lo que ha sido mi creencia de
vida que enseñar enseñar
enseñar aprender aprender aprender a las
personas que nos importan y de las
personas que nos importan vale la pena y
quiero cerrar ya en mi presentación
diciéndoles especialmente a las
juventudes que están en esta cosa que
ojalá que las personas que les importen
no sean sólo las cercanas sino que sean
todas todas todas las personas que se
cruzan en su trayectoria de vida para
que cuando lleguen como la abuelita que
ha estado saliendo al momento de decir
gracias vida nada te debo nada me debes
chau vida lo hagan con un sentido de
logro porque lo que es el vamos a ver lo
que son los logros y los aprendizajes
personales
que se quedan en uno mismo terminan no
teniendo valor terminan no teniendo
valor porque no aportan al cambio no
aportan al cambio para bien y entonces
son
de no consecuencia no producen
consecuencias y nadie ni usted ni
nosotros nadie quiere tener una vida que
no tenga consecuencia para nosotros para
cada uno de nosotros para cada uno de
ustedes tener una vida de consecuencia
es lo que nos puede llevar a donde
queremos hacer a donde queremos estar y
para costa rica por ahí anda una bandera
la para costa rica
en este momento en este momento más que
nunca de los que hemos vivido
necesita costa rica nos necesita para
que tengamos vidas consecuentes que
produzcamos consecuencias positivas
cambios positivos en nuestras propias
realidades y en las realidades de todas
las personas que estamos encuentre yo no
sé si sale el telón de cierre después de
esto porque es que desde el aprendizaje
permanente también se puede hacer patria
verdad eso es lo maravilloso aquí van a
ver ustedes yo les dije que me llamaba
milena cuando entré no les dije que mi
apellido era grillo
quiero decirles que me despido desde el
grillo del gran con el gusto maravilloso
de haber podido saltar con ustedes de
experiencia en experiencia y de
aprendizaje de aprendizaje y desearles
lo mejor de la vida de hoy en adelante
muchísimas gracias